Oh oh my goodness Nemo are you okay I
was campaigning for a sequel to Finding
Nemo I didn't think it would be finding
dory I had so that was a surprise I
remembered something that's not possible
is it
oh no oh okay sorry I suffer from
short-term memory loss I was worried
that my voice would start you know
changing and I couldn't be Dory anymore
so I'm I'm uh I'm hoping my voice
doesn't change too much more if we do
another sequel to this the top three
reasons we're excited to see finding
Dory well Disney pretty much had us at
Ellen but in case you need more first
there's the modern family connection I
play this disgruntled octopus named Hank
everybody does it nothing to be ashamed
of I don't like talking
I don't like chattering questions how
are you well we fine how are you well we
fine-tuned Bailey is sort of a neurotic
beluga whale who just lacks confidence
all right here there every word you're
saying about me the second reason the
making-of is more than impressive we got
an exclusive look inside the recording
booth where director Andrew Stanton
spent more than 200 18 hours with the
stars so if you want to give that like
one try not out of breath okay yeah he's
right there yes
then inside Pixar studios animators and
CGI artists spent more than eight months
drawing and creating the characters
everything had to be perfect right down
to Doris freckles finally the message in
this movie Dory's in search of her
parents voice by Eugene Levy and Diane
Keaton and while Dory's original motto
was just keep swimming it hasn't changed
much
what would Dory do is I guess a really
cool motto
there's not one speck of judgment in her
or meanness she's just happy she would
just be present she would just be there
and she would just do what needed to be
done you know no matter what
[Music]